[Music]
this is the tortoise uh
little swimming pool and then
some tortoises running around over there
so oh no way
why tortoises it was actually a gift but
i mean i don't know man i just really
love quarter through i think the
paintball field oh this is yeah so they
bring out these inflatable bunkers set
it up and then stop it dude stop it wait
wait wait wait wait i don't know man
i just love tortoises i just love
tortoises they're a gift but you know i
[ __ ] with them he's a humanitarian
brother
who would give a tortoise as a gift i
mean i guess devin did give me a [ __ ]
bearded dragon so there are people that
would do that he's just you know he's
trying to perform he's trying to get
into that like that other echelon of
rich i think they were a gift to shoot
and then he decided to
[Music]
yeah you can
this is my turtle hunting i mean turtle
sanctuary
yeah i do i put like a thousand miles on
my car your master i'm really about the
dirt stuff he's got a [ __ ] paintball
field in his house which is sick by the
way the only people he hangs out with
are like instagram models so i'm just
laughing at the thought of him being
like we could go play some paintball
and they're all like
no
come on if you like it it'd be fun it
doesn't hurt that bad come on yeah this
is dan
dan just trying he's trying to put on
the cool guy front but he's really just
showing all this [ __ ] to this host right
here in the hopes that the host will
come back and like play paintball with
him and ride dirt bikes and yeah thanks
for the interview dude like
you want to be friends you come over
like
after like work or whatever and like i'm
sure you got more interviews to do today
and stuff but like after you're done
with your interviews like
my mom doesn't care like she'll let us
do whatever and we can shoot i mean save
the turtles too
i just love i just love tortoises man
pulls out a [ __ ] desert eagle
i just love these [ __ ]
bunkers set it up and then yeah man and
you got the lights and everything yeah
no we're playing at like 2 a.m it's kind
of cool yeah i'd imagine you guys beat
each other up pretty good yeah i mean
you can get the bloody bloody welts man
it's no joke i mean like when you're
playing shirtless
what did he say
he said you can get bloody well i mean
when you're playing shirtless it can
happen sick dan
that's cool dude you saw my dab rigs
right
look this is this is crazy too there's a
[ __ ] dirt bike field i want to be
friends with dan bilzerian this is like
neverland ranch for like bitcoin guys
[Laughter]
like when you're playing shirtless
you'll it'll draw blood and why would
you play shirtless it's like an ego
thing man
why would you get the reference to go
out there and like do crazy like what
well i mean i'll bring out like some
money and then just have like one guy
against five of them and if he survives
i'll give him like a thousand bucks
running the gauntlet where you got like
15 guys on this side you know one guy
running down you know just wearing
underwear it's stupid
pause it pause it
i struggled to understand who would want
to hang out with him yeah you know what
i'm saying like just in terms of like
this would be fun
if you ended up at his place like we did
that one time right or us that would be
a lot of fun but if you're like one of
his friends and you come over and he's
like dude five grand to run across the
things shirtless right now and i'm just
gonna shoot the [ __ ] out of you five
grand the guy's like we could just have
a beer or two and watch the football
like came to hang out with you no dude
five grand for you to take out a dirt
bike right now
shirtless and do a dab break at the same
time and i'm gonna shoot you a paintball
gun what do you say
no
i love how
weirdly he seems um
bashful about this he's not really
saying this with like a ton of
confidence like it's almost like he's
telling on himself you know man we just
do stupid [ __ ] back here like uh
make someone get shirtless and run
across a paintball field and we all you
know like 15 people shooting them up
you know it's just like
it's just like
like you're not gonna tell on us right
like it's weird just like don't judge
dude like it's cool
[Laughter]
how much time do you spend in here yeah
maybe like five hours a week after that
it's kind of counterproductive in
sprints doing mma like there's a lot of
different ways to train this not you
know heavy weights and you have a
spelled out program yeah i mean my like
nutrition is super [ __ ] on point like
the sleep it just there's like a lot of
factors that go in it's not just working
out i learned a lot when i was doing
that biking bet so with uh that lance
helped coach you yeah yeah so you know
there's a decent amount of science you
know like when i was growing up it was
like rocky you know you'd eat the egg
whites and go run as hard as you could
and yeah you know it wasn't scientific
we're in the right manner yes this used
to be uh ice hockey and now it's kind of
you know a little basketball
tennis if you want to play volleyball we
got all the nets for that you know this
was how big i could turn that into a
little mma and then this is
the lockers for for paintball you want
to hit some balls
[Music]
what are the economics of this house
this is like a 50 million house yeah
well it's in vegas so that means it's
like 400 dollars yeah no i'm trying it's
it's definitely expensive as [ __ ] could
like rent this out
he could like start a gym membership to
this part of his house like a
social club or something you know like a
country club the video is like kind of
over now honestly you just got like a
foam pit and a trampoline next to that
for whatever reason i mean it's it's
sick um you know someone's gonna see
this and be like you guys are just
jealous yeah we are yeah hell yeah i'm
jealous but i don't think you need this
why do you want batting cages in your
house you know i realized i kind of like
going to the gym i get kind of lonely
when i do that [ __ ] at home i mean i
don't have a gym at home but i have like
a peloton and i have some weights
outside i get a little bit lonely
sometimes i like going to the gym and
being around people and
like i just feel like this would just is
so isolating if you wanted to play
tennis go to where people play tennis
you don't need one in your [ __ ] house
no i agree with that the only thing here
that is worth keeping really you know
like the thing like i think you need
is the paintball field you need that and
sure you you need both of those
you definitely need the dirt bike area
and
and the foam pit i want i want to say a
foam pit
pretty yeah
yeah and i mean
the dab breaks too yeah definitely keep
the dab rigs the batting cages are i
mean i wouldn't mind having that at my
place too yeah even just to practice i
don't know if he still does it in this
house but remember in his old house like
he did like one of these and he's
bragging about how he has guns in every
room just like lying around i just
remember thinking like you're just
guaranteeing that the theft is gonna be
easier
i don't know why i'm just imagining him
his home gets invaded by someone and
he's like there he's home and he's like
oh [ __ ] i got this and he picks up a big
gun and goes in the room tries to shoot
it but it's a dab rig
[ __ ] i grabbed the wrong thing he pulls
the trigger and it's glass it just
doesn't move he's like it just goes [ __ ]
some smoke comes out i thought you were
going to say robert like the robber's
like wait a minute that shit's sick by
the way he's like yeah you want to hit
and then the robber goes up to like do a
hit
and then and then
he was like dude to be honest like it's
all love like i thought i was gonna take
some [ __ ] honestly like i just i think
you're really cool and he's like dan's
like no no for sure and then he goes to
hit the gun dab rig and then there's a
gun hidden inside the dab rig and he
shoots the dude psych it's a it's a dab
red it's a dab rig gun hybrid [ __ ]
he grabs a gun and he goes out into the
living room but all the all the robbers
grabbed all the guns in the other rooms
they just shoot him the [ __ ] up like he
just doesn't even last two seconds
get out of my
it's in his closet
he can't find his guns because there's
this way too many chlamydia tests
he's opening up the cabinets and
chlamydia tests are pouring out and he's
like what the [ __ ] climbing over
chlamydia tests to get to the gun
why do i buy so many of these he finally
finds one it shoots one of the robbers
it's a paintball gun no dude he pulls
out a paintball gun and he shoots it and
a [ __ ] and a blood drawing needle
comes out